big vault I was living in France I
stayed there for three years once twice
a week I treated myself to the most
amazing bold breakfast and he started
off with these beauties here no gays
cheap but incredibly tasty start off
with a nice hot pan no gays in its a
very spicy sausage doesn't need any help
does he leave chili just a touch of salt
and pepper you can smell the spice they
started release all that wonderful oil
that flavor in there add a couple of
cloves are finely sliced garlic spread
the garlic across the pan it instantly
changes color takes on this nice dark
rich golden color now take a look with a
heat out for the parsley the stalks of
sobs like parsley and coriander can be
used to impart flavor during cooking but
the leaves should always be added just
before serving to give maximum color and
fragrance
and then finish that up with Mike APIs
now take your question there literally
24 hours old so they're crispy on the
outside and just slice off the lid this
recipe is a great way to use up any
leftover croissants from the day before
I used to cringe when I saw the French
cooks throw away quests on least a cried
thinking oh my god
any idea what he's throwing away in
terms of flavor
whatever you do do not wipe out that pan
dunk your quests on mopping up all that
amazing flavor and Kara I think the
inside for that beautiful don't forget
the lids and then get your thumbs go
inside the croissant
all I want to do now is just create a
little pocket and just manipulate the
croissant now this is where it gets
exciting mix up the Kapus garlic and
sausages with a color all that wonderful
delicious flavored oil now some cheese
but not just any cheese fontina cheese
is like a number one cheese for grilling
and because it's a very rich cheese you
shave it thinner than you would a white
truffle but it gives a really nice
saltiness and a light smoky flavor
such a pepper result
place these big boys on the tray
literally 30 seconds on the grill here
we go nice crisp packs full of flavor
now top them and that for me it's almost
like being back in Paris except this
time I don't have to share them with the
French my ultimate big and bold
breakfast Merguez and fontina stuff
croissants a great way to start the day
[Music]